People get bubbly around the end of the year.
Or during weddings.
Or on their birthdays.
Or really anytime, because champagne seems
to be EVERYWHERE NOW.
What's up with that?
From the end of November until early January
is great for sparkling wine sales.
Traditionally champagne, which is the most
famous type of sparking wine, seeing sales
peaking around holidays related to romance
and celebration.
Like New Year, or Valentines Day.
There are also peaks at Christmas and Thanksgiving;
during wedding season, and every Sunday when
we have brunch at my house.
Bubbly beverages are super popular, but who
decided bubbles meant pleasure?
It seems kind of weird if you step back from
it all and think about it right?
Carbonated water was created for sailors in
1767 by an English chemist to mimic the effervescent
mineral waters of Europe, but became popular
around the continent after the French Revolution
as a holy-water replacement for secular rituals.
Bubbly beverages, like sparkling wine, contain
bubbles because of the yeast microorganisms
which ferment the liquids by eating the sugars
and pooping out alcohol and carbon dioxide
gas.
True champagne, from the Champagne region
of France, is notoriously finicky to create.
They want to get JUST the right mixture of
bubbles, sugars and sweetness.
Once it reaches the perfect balance, the vintners
move the frothy liquid into the tightly sealed
bottles which are twice the pressure of a
car tire -- five and a half regular atmosphere..
This forces the extra CO2 to dissolve into
the liquid and combine with water to become
carbonic acid… for a while.
When you pop the cork, the unstable carbonic
acid comes out of the solution, causing the
CO2 to come out of solution in an endothermic
reaction (that is to say, it cools itself)
AND VOILA!!
Celebration time, c'mon!!
The vapor is over the mouth of the bottle
is that endothermic reaction creating a pocket
of condensed water vapor, it's like seeing
your breath in the winter.
So the bubbles themselves are just tiny pockets
of dissolved carbon dioxide, left over from
the yeast fermentation.
And they’re important because they affect
how we experience the flavor and aroma of
an effervescent drink; it's like a tiny fountain,
stirring the champagne and adding tiny particles
of goodness to the air around the glass.
Eventually, the air pockets dissolve, as does
the amount of CO2 in your champ, causing the
bubbles to slow.
But what is it that makes a bubbly drink so
enjoyable?
Other animals HATE bubbles, because they're
a sign of food spoilage, but the NIH studied
bubbly water to see what makes it cool, what
makes it poppin', and they found an enzyme
on the sour receptors of our tongue called
carbonic anhydrase 4 (CA-IV); the bubbles
stimulate the sour buds and somatosensory
system.
The somatosensory system normally activates
for temperature, pain, touch and taste; so
you'd think sour buds, and pain… that doesn't
seem good, but for some reason the dual activation
of the buds and the nerves creates a pleasurable
sensation for the brain; even though we probably
SHOULD experience it as pain and sour.
Scientists with the NIH think it might be
because the bubbles are made of carbon dioxide,
and so they trigger CA-IV differently.
Normally the enzyme helps us convert carbon
dioxide and water to bicarbonate and protons
so the body can balance the acids and bases
in the bloodstream… so this was an unexpected
tickle.
Sort of like how spicy foods trigger pain
and we like those?
Do you like your beverages with bubbles?
Without?
How are you celebrating your
new year?!